unrelenting rain hits already flooded
regions in australia's east
some towns in the state of new south
wales now resemble
islands cut off by rising flood waters
and surrounded by debris those who
didn't leave are stranded
with no way out including in pit town
west of sydney
paul zamet left in time but has been
watching as flood waters rise around his
home
fencing tools and cars already lost
it really is it's an absolute disaster
i'm not kidding
i don't know how i'll afford it next
door is a building company
underwater it's owner already counting
the costs
um it hasn't sunk in yet but i feel
pretty upset for ourselves and
everybody else i suppose yeah the scale
of this unfolding crisis
is enormous thousands of people have
been forced to leave their homes
many rescued by boat or helicopter and
areas declared
natural disaster zones authorities say
sydney's largest dam will likely spill
over
for days threatening highly populated
areas people are using
boats and kayaks to rescue animals and
salvage anything they can from the flood
waters
the cleanup will be immense and the
damage bill is expected to tip
into the billions of dollars
right now the focus is on ensuring
people
and animals are safe rain is forecast to
ease in the coming days
but the flood threat is expected to
remain
the strong warning we need to give
people is please continue to be patient
because we envisage that even when the
rain stops
in some of these coastal communities the
rivers will keep rising
people living in low-lying areas of new
south wales are no strangers to floods
but this one
many say is unlike anything they've seen
nicola gage al jazeera pitt town